[Music]
on this sunday night back to school with
new covert rule concerns and confusion
with some provinces dropping isolation
and mask requirements current levels
across the country are five to ten times
higher the new year could be off to a
precarious start plus missed
vaccinations for some of them it felt
less than one percent the pandemic's
impact that could be felt decades from
now interest rate hike anxiety with
another bump expected this week home
affordability takes another hit and
mar-a-lago
was a travesty of justice what the
mar-a-lago raid could mean for donald
trump's influence and his white house
ambitions
[Music]
global national with bara nasser
reporting tonight colleen christie
good evening thanks for joining us we
begin tonight with breaking news out of
saskatchewan police are looking for two
suspects after a horrific stabbing spree
ten people have been killed and more
than a dozen others have been injured in
multiple locations a manhunt is now
underway for two suspects identified as
damian sanderson and miles sanderson
police say some of the victims appear to
have been targeted but others were
stabbed at random the attacks happened
in several locations including james
smith cree nation and the village of
weldon officers say the suspects were
last spotted shortly after noon local
time in regina the suspects may be
traveling in a black nissan rogue with
saskatchewan license number 119 mpi a
province-wide dangerous person alert has
been issued and extended into alberta
and manitoba
given the fact that they are in a
vehicle we can't say with 100 certainty
where they are right now and
we believe it's prudent to notify the
residents of those provinces that there
is a possibility they could have
traveled to those locations and making
them aware of this current situation
that we're dealing with
police say the suspects are considered
armed and dangerous anyone with
information is asked to contact police
this labor day weekend marks the end of
summer and a third pandemic back to
school season despite higher vaccination
rates indicators are cobit 19 will surge
again and the biggest concerns may be in
ontario where most pandemic restrictions
have been lifted as ross lord reports
some feel we may be letting our guard
down too soon
it's now an annual anxiety how to
conduct classes safely without making
the covet 19 pandemic worse i have two
kids under the age of five and you know
providing them with virtual schooling is
not easy and so getting them into a
school setting where they can be there
continuously over the coming school year
to me is really important fahad razek is
not just a parent he's an epidemiologist
and he's worried wastewater indicators
suggest another increase in covert 19 is
coming current levels uh across the
country relative to just a year ago are
five to ten times higher depending on
the test you're looking at razak says
it's too early for ontario's decision to
remove isolation requirements for those
who become infected fearing it could
lead to asymptomatic staff and students
returning to schools while still
contagious
a view shared by the union for ontario
high school teachers and other school
staff we should be celebrating right now
going back to school face to face but
it's being a little bit clouded by the
the fear around covid offsetting some of
that fear is canada approving an updated
covet 19 vaccine to target the first
highly contagious omicron variant
ontario is urging anyone with new or
worsening symptoms to stay home until
their symptoms improve for at least 24
hours some provinces and territories are
still recommending masks in classrooms
and other crowded spaces even if they're
no longer mandatory if they're ill
especially with new cold or flu-like
symptoms that they need to stay home
and not just go off to school uh and
arrange for testing for coconut as
appropriate everyone is tired of the
pandemic no one wants to hear what
medical experts say remains true
that with so many swirling variables
what happens next in the covet 19
equation is impossible to figure out
ross lord global news
covenanting vaccines have been critical
in saving lives their economy and their
return to a more normal way of life but
other vaccination rates have fallen
during the pandemic
families put routine medical checkups on
hold visiting their doctors only for
urgent matters that means many children
are now behind on other important
immunizations karen lieberman reports on
the push by this country's health care
professionals to get those kids up to
date
as children return to classrooms across
the country they may be missing more
than the summer break
there's a huge gap you know all those
kids that normally get vaccines in grade
seven
they didn't
the kovid 19 pandemic led to a lag in
routine doctor visits and immunizations
so we have this massive catch up to do
in ontario the number of
twelve-year-olds vaccinated against
meningococcal disease hepatitis b and
human papilloma virus decreased
dramatically in the last school year
family physician dr noah ivers says a
simple shot in the arm protects against
these vaccine preventable diseases
hepatitis a cause of liver failure and
liver cancer
we have a meningitis
vaccine and we have one that prevents
cervical cancer and anal cancer in
toronto a meningitis outbreak left one
person dead two others ill
meningococcal infection makes people get
very sick very quickly and you can die
human papillomavirus and hepatitis b
don't kill people right away now
they will be killing people from
cervical cancer and liver cancer in
decades
experts say vaccine hesitancy isn't to
blame for the backlog rather
interruptions to in-person learning
normally if you know uptake of these
vaccines in the 65 to 80 percent range
for some of them it felt less than one
percent
dr jahu and the team from 19 to zero a
non-profit made up of academics and
public health experts among others hope
to improve vaccine uptake pointing to
results of a survey they conducted which
found most parents agreed it's important
for their children to get the hpv
vaccine but less than half were aware of
which vaccines are given in grade seven
they don't recognize that they are as
important for boys as they are for girls
you know certainly we think a lot about
cervical cancer
but hiv is actually one of the leading
causes of head and neck cancers as well
and i think a lot of parents don't know
that that's right as students catch up
in the classroom doctors hope they will
also get caught up on vaccines karen
lieberman global news toronto
canadians are seeing the highest
inflation rates in four decades the bank
of canada is expected to hike interest
rates again this week in an effort to
stabilize the economy global's brittany
rosen explains why the move is needed
and who feel it the most
high gas prices
high food prices high house prices
strapped for cash the cost of living has
become unbearable for the average
canadian we've been seeing inflation
running at the highest in 40 years while
inflation has peaked it remains steep
sitting at 7.6 percent in july the bank
of canada is widely expected to hike
interest rates again on wednesday by up
to three quarters of a percentage point
in an effort to stabilize inflation
there's still a long way to go and so
increasing interest rates is the
greatest way of achieving that mandate
and bringing it down while the higher
cost to borrow money is expected to cool
inflation homeowners up for a mortgage
renewal or those with variable rates
will likely be hit with sticker shock
that could essentially mean especially
on some of these mega mortgages a few
extra hundred dollars coming out of your
bank account every single month on the
flip side experts predict the move will
help make life more affordable
especially for those trying to enter
canada's scorching hot real estate
market housing prices have been
exponentially high from coast to coast
with double-digit price increases since
the start of the pandemic part of the
solution is get the interest rates up to
cool the economy home ownership is very
sensitive to interest rates much more
sensitive than buying a cell phone or a
laptop because real estate costs so much
money there are signs of things starting
to cool already the latest numbers from
august showing housing sales dropped by
a whopping 40 percent in vancouver and
34 percent in toronto last month an
indicator that house prices are also
starting to decline the predictions are
the upcoming rate hike would be second
to last we could see another one next
month as for a potential recession some
experts say it is possible although if
it were to happen it would likely be
mild brittany rosen global news toronto
to the situation in flood street in
pakistan engineers have intentionally
breached the country's largest
freshwater lake to release rising waters
the diversion has displaced up to 100
000 people but it's hoped it will
protect about half a million people who
live in nearby towns more rain is
predicted to hit the southern part of
the country in the coming days more than
1300 people have been killed and more
than 33 million others have been
affected by historic flooding
in ukraine several regions have come
under russian fire again shattering the
lives of people who live there
new video shows the horrific conditions
ukrainians are enduring emergency
services in harkie have released these
images of firefighters rescuing a kitten
after a rocket attack on a restaurant
and hotel
the animal was said to be shaken but
okay
and look at this close call in central
ukraine a driver narrowly missed an
explosion it happened a split second
before the car reached the intersection
further south airstrikes hit a family
clinic and a power line in the port city
of mikalive the clinic's pediatric
department is in ruins on the able to
treat children
for the first time since the raid on his
florida estate former u.s president
donald trump spoke at a political rally
and he didn't hold back blasting the fbi
the reasons for the search and u.s
president joe biden and as jennifer
johnson explains trump told his
supporters the department of justice
investigation won't stop him from
becoming america's president again
with supporters cheering him on former
president donald trump launched a
blistering attack against u.s president
joe biden and the fbi after federal
investigators confiscated boxes of top
secret documents from his florida home
the shameful raid and break-in of my
home mar-a-lago
was a travesty of justice
that made a mockery of
america's laws traditions and principles
the former president then took direct
aim at the current president who he may
face in a 2024 bid for the white house
the biden administration invaded the
home of their
chief political opponent
who is absolutely destroying him and
everyone else in the polls i hate to say
it
the white house maintains the department
of justice is independent from the biden
administration and that president biden
only learned of the fbi raid after it
happened but trump was right in saying
he's leading all of the republican
presidential hopefuls in most polls
despite his controversial actions this
raid in their house i really think was a
very political move and it comes off
very political i believe it's a lot of
wish i guess him
he'll be elected president again
because we're the people who can pull
him back in but investigators claim
trump refused multiple legal requests to
turn over the highly sensitive documents
and now could face charges including
espionage and obstruction of justice
potentially stopping any future white
house run these are all serious crimes
that could get
the former president criminally charged
and incarcerated what influence trump
still has over his party may be evident
in the midterm elections just over 60
days away the president has endorsed
several candidates including two at this
rally but whether his support still
carries enough weight to win remains to
be seen
jennifer johnson global news washington
coming up the trial begins for the
horrific terror attack that claimed 86
lives
it was the scene of a horrific attack
that left 86 people dead a man in nice
france deliberately drove a truck
through crowded streets before police
shot and killed him
now six years later eight people accused
of helping the driver are set to go on
trial and as mike armstrong reports the
victims families will be watching
closely
there was never a moment jacqueline
dubler says
when he didn't know exactly what was
happening buble was on the beach in nice
july 14 2016 and heard a loud noise on
the street right away he says he knew it
was an attack
is now the president of a group called
life for nice it's an association
representing victims and their families
himself didn't lose anyone but he lived
through it
[Music]
says it was hard he held a woman's hand
as she took her last breath and there
were others dead and dying all around
more than 450 people were injured and 86
killed the weapon a 19-ton cargo truck
driven by a 31-year-old tunisian man he
was eventually shot by police
isis would claim responsibility it had
called on followers wherever they lived
to attack civilians
family members and neighbors of the
driver said he'd been radicalized in the
weeks before the attack
now there were arrests in the days
following well monday some of those
people will go on trial
seven men and one woman will be tried in
this paris courtroom it was specially
built for another terror trial 20 people
were found guilty in june for their
roles in the november 2015 batacla
attacks
now only three suspects in the nice
attack face terror-related charges
prosecutors say they helped the driver
obtain weapons and rent the truck the
five others are accused of arms
trafficking and helping indirectly
says some of the families hope the trial
helps them move on in their healing but
he says others are still too angry for
it to make a difference
there's also disappointment the man who
was behind the wheel never faced justice
mike armstrong global news
i had how french language issues could
tip the balance in the next federal
election
more than half of quebec residents
believe the use of french across the
country is under threat that's according
to internal government polling
commissioned by the prime minister's
office and obtained by global news that
belief alone may pose a threat to the
liberal government's chances of winning
the next election our chief political
correspondent david aiken explains
days before the beginning of the quebec
provincial election statistics canada
had some bad news the latest census data
revealed that the proportion of french
speakers has declined everywhere in
canada including in quebec that's a data
point that pushed language to the center
of that election yes absolutely so
language is uh
always a significant issue in quebec
incumbent premier francois lego is miles
ahead in the polls and so if he needs
someone to blame about the decline of
french well it will not be his
provincial opponents the answer is
justin trudeau right and it's the
federal government jan plant was a top
political aid to ministers in the harper
government and he's played key roles in
fighting federal campaigns in quebec
what i expect that we will see primarily
ago more and more talking about
justin trudeau and the federal
government and asking quebecers for
another strong mandate so that we can
continue to be strong you know facing
ottawa to protect our language protect
our identity
the trudeau liberals have won three
elections largely based on strong
support in quebec but if that quebec
support waivers and it could over
language policy well that's trouble for
the liberals they can't afford to start
losing ground in francophones
communities not only in quebec but all
across canada and could make victory for
the conservatives easier federal
liberals are
are vulnerable on language and on quebec
identity more generally that's why the
internal polling from last april was
crucial for the trudeau government to
ensure that they are on the right track
with what quebecers want done to boost
french language use in the rest of the
country
sixty percent of quebecers want
increased funding for post-secondary
institutions outside of quebec that
offer instruction in french
sixty percent of quebecers want more
money for french immersion in the rest
of the country and fifty six percent
want funding to help entrepreneurs do
business in french in the rest of canada
the anxiety about the future of french
not only in quebec but elsewhere in
canada is something that is you know
featured in that data the poll also said
65 percent of quebecers said
guaranteeing the equality of french and
english right across the country should
be a top federal priority the trudeau
government promised to do that with an
overhaul to the official languages act
and that overhaul will be on
parliament's agenda when mps return to
the house of commons later this month
david aiken global news ottawa
next a new library for vancouver that's
about so much more than books
with control her shot high her
condolences to our southern neighbors
tonight after team canada beat team usa
again for the top prize at hockey's
women's world championship final the two
rival women's teams faced off in a
rematch after canada previously
outscored the americans both in last
year's final and the olympic gold medal
game earlier this year canada's women
came out victorious once more tonight
with a final score of two to one
a brand new library has just opened its
doors in vancouver and it's like no
other the city has ever seen it's called
the vancouver black library and the ubc
student behind the project says it's
bigger than books she hopes the new
space will start a new chapter for the
city's black community paul johnson
reports
it was dark stairway but your face
lights up soaking up the ambience in
vancouver's newest culture space for
maya preshon this is a dream turned
reality it happened definitely
sooner than i could have imagined
rewind back to the middle of winter when
maya told us about her vision of a
library that would tell the story of
vancouver's black community at the time
she had no location no funding just the
moxie of a university student who wanted
to do something and what a doer she is
in the 70s there was a neighborhood that
was a community hub for black people in
vancouver and that was hogan's alley and
it was dismantled to make way for city
infrastructure
overlooked and unknown to many east
vancouver's hogan's alley at its roots
in the black men who worked as stewards
on the trains that came to nearby
pacific central station
jimi hendrix's grandmother lived there
and musicians like nat king cole and
louis armstrong would eat at its
restaurants when they came through town
the city's role in demolishing it for
the georgia viaduct is now a lesson in
what not to do it was the kind of tenor
of the time that was just how things
they viewed inner cities as blight they
viewed ethnic enclaves of something to
get rid of not something to embrace
hogan's alley is just one of the stories
you can learn about at the vancouver
black library now operating in a
building full of art spaces in chinatown
everyone is welcome and you'll find
books by black authors about all kinds
of black stories all available thanks to
maya and her volunteers
and finished in time so she can get back
to class at ubc it's all just crowd
funding crowd support knowledge from the
community contributions from the
community what are the chances we'll be
hearing about maya preston again
paul johnson global news
what an accomplishment that's global
national for this sunday night i'm
colleen christie tonight's york canada
is this rainbow near agassi bc we love
seeing your canada please keep emailing
your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching eric sorenson will
be at the anchor desk tomorrow good
night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you